the Joe Rogan experience I've seen every
single fight you've ever had so for me
it's an honor to have you in here man as
a giant boxing fan all the way back to
Dwight Kyle we saw you fight in the
Olympics so everything every day yeah
yeah for real
and I understand you you're gonna do an
exhibition now
well yeah I'm preparing for one you know
you know me going over going over to
Japan and being able to go there and see
the Tahoe whatever that tsunami sit on
me yeah and the point of sending tsunami
going over there and helping people and
I think it why not do a exhibition right
so it's like a benefit for the tsunami
victims yes you look great
you're in great shape still well thank
you you know you never got out of shape
well yeah I did a game yeah easy to
maintain your e-bill easier to maintain
them rebuild yeah but now at your age
like what most last time you had a fight
was like 2011 mm so it's been like eight
years which is you were thinking of
competing like deep in your 50s though
well yeah the thing is is that I'm
always trying to stay in shape but
really didn't want to get hit again
right right right like that but and
that's but exhibition I I could do
exhibition who is the exhibition against
I don't know yet I'm not I'm thinking
about you know I wanted to be ready both
got me here but now you could do it with
somebody you friends with right they
know that they not gonna hit you too
hard you'll hit them too hard
right so it'll be more of a sparring yes
a deal yes now how often you training
now well you know I'm always trainer I
shout a box I don't I don't I don't hit
the bag but I'm I'm ready to do it now
because I'm actually gonna be performing
mm-hmm I wanna I want to look good but
but it is I don't want to get in a
doggy-dog good fight right you don't
want to get into a war right you just
want to have like a
exhibition sparring match just a little
just combinations not hate each other
too hard that kind of deal well yeah I
we hit we can hit hard to the body right
not here right right right
now at this stage of your life you know
it's been a while since you competed are
you worried that those competitive
juices might get fired up again we might
want to actually fight again I know I
don't think I don't think I will ever go
back in because I did everything I
wanted to do right I feel that I got as
far as I've wanted to get and you know I
I'm on the prototype Midway champ of the
world ever but I'm still ain't got no
reason to be mad with nobody bout
anything and I think I had a great great
career you had an unbelievable career
[Applause]